one of our favorites from the worldwide
leader in sports
baseball insider senior insider i'll
just keep you're an executive vice
president of insider
information uh from espn jeff passon how
are you jeff
i i think uh the last time i played
torrey pines was my wedding weekend
almost 15 years ago and i'm pretty sure
i was too over after the first hole
okay i think phil's doing great
excellent very good
very very good uh did you use any um
any pine tar to improve the grip on your
clubs that day jeff
or all right you know if i used pine car
or spider tack or anything i would still
be absolutely awful
so i i did not need to use foreign
substances to suck
[Music]
let's get into i don't know where to get
into this um
let's let's start with where we are now
before we get into the
why we why we are now here where are we
now on this subject matter
with baseball and its pitchers and
hitters who are on various sides of this
subject
i you know sometimes rich i like uh
contextualizing things
not by looking backward but by looking
forward okay and we are
we are four days away uh from one of the
most
interesting days i've had in almost 20
years i've been covering baseball
which is the day that foreign substance
enforcement is going to begin
you have to remember baseball has not
suspended a player for foreign
substances
in more than six years and all of a
sudden
we may have a rash of suspensions coming
down because umpires are going to be
like psh it's
checking guys for things between innings
practically running them through
sticky substance detectors and trying to
figure out on the fly
something that baseball for the longest
time has just accepted as normal
and it's a sea change and it's
fascinating because
there are great points i think on all
sides
um major league baseball says we don't
want people to cheat
that's a reasonable thing to say i get
it and
and i like that idea but major league
baseball also
has allowed cheating to proliferate to
the point
where it got so excessive that they felt
like they had to do something about it
players on the other hand say yeah you
know we don't want people to cheat
either but
the balls we feel like after having
thrown them with sticky stuff on our
hands for as long as we have
it's gonna be a really difficult thing
to do and yeah it is
like you know a tiger can't sit there
and wish it
stripes away and and players similarly
can't sit there and say after years of
doing something a particular way
that changing is going to be easy or
reasonable or good
so there are a lot of dynamics at play
here
and the intersection of them all makes
for a really
fascinating rich story so let's get into
i guess what's going to happen four days
from now uh
like literally when a pitcher comes into
a game
warms up finishes the inning the
umpire already probably knows what this
scouting report from central baseball is
on this particular picture
right yep and then that particular
picture strolls off the mound what
happens
if they feel like this guy actually did
something
that coming into the game they were
suspecting of him of what happens
like how does this work you know it i i
don't even know
if it's uh suspecting necessarily i mean
the starting pitchers are going to get
checked at least
twice that's what the the rule says and
relief pitchers are going to get
checked as well uh in after the inning
they first throw so
umpires uh you know home plate empire
every inning is gonna walk over
to the dugout and is gonna
look at the belt gonna look at the pants
gonna look at the hands gonna look at
the jersey gonna look at the hack and
look at all these different things
i i mean one guy i'm really interested
to see is
craig kimbrell um craig kimbrell's hat
is one of the most disgusting things on
earth
like i would not want to be anywhere
near that it's just got this
big gross splotch right in the middle of
the brim
and i'll be curious to see if craig
kimball comes out with a brand new fresh
hat that doesn't have anything in there
and and by the way i am
not trying to single out craig kimbrell
here i want to make it clear
that a vast majority of pitchers in
baseball
use something to get grip on the ball
and that's part of the issue here
i i think the the reason that it's
blowing up the way that it is
beyond the fact that it is against the
letter of the law
um is is the just how widespread it
really is
i mean there are a lot of guys rich who
are using something
and you know considering you have a rule
on the book
saying that that's wrong boy it just
makes for
uh an interesting situation um
and you don't know how different umpires
are gonna enforce it are there gonna be
some guys who are real sticklers are
there going to be some guys who say yeah
that doesn't look like too much sticky
stuff you can go out and do it like
what's the line it's a very arbitrary
thing
and in the arbitrariness of it makes me
wonder
whether some umpires are going to get
the reputation as guys who will allow a
little bit of leeway whereas others
uh are simply not going to what a hot
mess jeff
i mean oh yeah because because you know
it there's there's no other way to put
it hot mess
because it will be just because
there are you know 30 clubs
15 games a day right and and
and 15 different umpiring units and
thus there will be what appears to be
different
applications of the enforcement
by nature that there's 15 different ones
and it will come across potentially as
arbitrary and capricious and baseball
can see that coming down the pike
there's no question about that
and so the the the question i have about
that is why won't they head it off at
the pass
by sitting down and coming up with
a substance that everybody agrees
is copacetic put it on the mound for
everyone to see
and forget about it set it and forget it
why
why can't that be done why can't that be
done in the next
90 hours i mean garrett cole last night
jeff
pleaded for baseball to listen to us
said we know you have the hammer
so what what why why can't that be done
with a bunch of smart people who
know this is the last thing anybody
wants everybody
so so i think there are a few things
here let's start with the substance
itself
what is proper what is right
what is good what is not cheating but is
sticky
it's almost like you're looking for this
mystery substance rich that does not
exist
because the let's go back to why this
has become a problem in the first place
pitchers started understanding how
important spin was
organization started emphasizing spin
and i'm sorry but naturally getting more
spin out of your pitches
you know multiple hundreds of
revolutions per minute is
almost a near impossibility like you
gain spin as you gain velocity typically
but you know there's a finite amount of
velocity left in your arm before it's
going to explode because you're taxing
it too much
and so picture start an understanding
hold on a second
if i use an extremely sticky substance
the the one thing that affects spin the
most
is friction and that's why they are
using stuff like spider tack which is
made by a strong man in order to hold
300 pound atlas stones
um as opposed to five ounce baseballs uh
they're using it
because it works and so major league
baseball doesn't want to go out there
and put something on the mound that
helps players essentially cheap
and yet by treating spider tack the same
way that they are
pine tar or a combination of sunscreen
and rosin
uh they're they're essentially saying
that
those are the same whereas at the same
time they're trying and have been trying
to develop
some kind of substance that could be
universally used
it's it's silly and it's illogical
to go cold turkey when the league is
trying to do something
that would not be cold turkey and so i
i've said from the beginning
either put a a thing of sunscreen out on
the mound
and allow umpires to watch players
apply it or put a pine tar rag out on
the mountain and allow
umpires to watch players dab at it like
there
are solutions and there should be but a
big part of the problem here rich
is that the sides just don't get along
and haven't sat down
with one another to talk about this and
because of that
unfortunately we end up with this
situation
jeff i've been saying over the last two
days for sure
that when i heard what glass now had to
say and what cole had to say
over the last two days i'm not sitting
here and focused on
the sticky stuff i'm saying when you've
got
hitters saying central baseball's not
protecting us
because they're letting these pitchers
do all this stuff with the baseball
and then there's other hitters saying
central baseball is not protecting us
because they're taking that stuff away
from the pitchers and they're going to
hit us in the face
and then you got pictures saying central
baseball is not protecting us
because they're making me go cold turkey
and now i've got a rehab
hoping to get back my career in order
for the playoffs
all of them basically saying central
baseball is not protecting us
and what cole had to say was we know he
got the hammer talk to us
i'm sitting here saying they got a
collective bargaining agreement to
figure this thing out there's no way the
hell they're going to get this done when
there's billions on the table and they
don't trust each other even figure this
thing out
uh you know that's my real concern that
this is just the latest symptom
another symptom was last year where they
couldn't figure out what the schedule
was going to be during the pandemic and
damn near had a lockout almost
you know what i mean like so uh uh i'm
chilling no no all right listen
all of that is is right what has
happened here
is a function of a relationship that's
broken
and they don't trust each other and they
think that
both sides are operating in bad faith
and it becomes unfortunately a really
problematic thing
when you have something like this that
should have a solution
right like there should be a solution to
this yeah
or a reasonable solution a compromise
but there isn't a physical solution that
you could put on a baseball you know
what i mean like
i i i ah why why did baseball
not deal with this in in the uh in the
off season
well i mean you could see this coming
down the pike right uh
or the fact that i i i will say i will
say this how are we here
i know you want to look forward but i
mean looking back is definitely why
we're here
no no no looking no i just wanted to
look forward for what's fascinating
coming up looking
back is is is important it's imperative
to have context for this
and and i think when you're looking back
uh the the
fault that you can place on major league
baseball
and the teams in front offices as well
is twofold uh
number one it's uh both tacitly
um and explicitly encouraging players to
use this sort of thing i mean there are
some organizations
that hire chemists to go out and
make like really good sticky stuff um
and and the idea that organizations are
going to pictures and saying
spin spin spin smith's been vilovilo
vilovilo
as opposed to hey let's control command
the baseball
like that shows you where the game is
gone and a big reason
why you see all the strikeouts you do
these days and why the pace of the game
is slowed down to a snails is is
because of this um but major league
baseball's known about this for a long
time
and for a while mlb listened
to the players and and the hitters
especially were saying hey
we want these guys to have substances
because they feel like they can
control the ball better that way and
there is an
element of truth to that it was just the
give us an inch and we'll take a mile
or give us an inch and we'll take a
marathon that's what happened
here you know baseball made this okay
and because
something like sunscreen rosin or pine
tar which has
been used for decades was deemed okay
other pitcher said well that's okay then
what can really juice our spin and make
us even better
and teams were hiring chemists
jeff did i hear that right like
literally there's a scientific wing of a
certain
major league baseball club or clubs to
figure out what's the best substance to
put on a glove or a hat or a belt or
inside here inside there
i mean i mean rich this has been this
has been this is nothing new
um there you know there there's a i
don't know if it's apocryphal i don't
believe it is
story uh of a pitcher who will combine
um it's called a moto stick um which is
the pine tar stick that pictures you or
that batter's use and
you see them rubbing it on uh on the uh
handle of their batch um it's it's a
motor stick
uh liquid pine tar uh and coca-cola
and they put it inside of a coke can
and use a lighter underneath and
melt it i mean it's it's like drugs
and the stuff hardens up and this is the
substance of choice uh for for a number
of guys
um there was a a former clubhouse
attendant for the los angeles angels
named brian harkins
and uh everyone called him bubba
and bubba had some of the best stuff in
the league
and you know he ended up getting fired
last year
because of this and because mlb had sent
out a memo saying hey if any
uh club employees are known to be aiding
and abetting in this
they're going to be held responsible
well he sued the the
angels in major league baseball and in
his lawsuit
he named garrett cole and gave text
messages he named
max renamed justin verlander he named
adam wainwright you know he
he dimed on a bunch of guys and those
aren't small names that i'm saying
they're rich
like those are guys who uh are are among
the elite in the game
and yeah i don't sit here and
and question their accomplishments or
uh their ability to be great baseball
players
but there is a you know there's a
there's a continuum on which you look at
the actions of guys and what they're
doing and
uh this certainly is not on the side of
the continuum
where you think a guy like ken griffey
jr was clean in an era
where there were you know rampant peds
like
you have to look at pictures a little
bit differently and their
accomplishments a little bit differently
because of it and
we'll always sit there and wonder uh you
know how good would this guy have been
otherwise
i don't know if it's just just the the
century we live in jeff
um but you know we had broad career on
last
show and i asked him about this very
subject and he was talking about he told
he tells gaylord perry
you know back in the day you know he
putting whatever you want to put on the
ball just hit the dry side of it like
you know and
and we'd laugh like that's ha ha that's
when baseball was great and
maybe this is just this different
version of that or or that is at least
whatever the hell he was putting on it's
not like you know
weapons-grade material that a team is
asking a chemist
you know this goes back rich just goes
back a century remember
the spitball was outlawed in 2000 or in
1920 rather
like that this is loading up the ball
has been going back a long time it's a
little different
uh in in gaylord perry's era because
gaylord perry was
you know he was a sinker baller he was
putting wet stuff on the ball
as opposed to sticky stuff he was trying
to get less spin
on it because with sinkers the less spin
you have
the more the ball dives now baseball's
become a four-seam fastball
and breaking ball game and the more spin
you can get on your four-step fastball
the higher it stays in the zone so
you know the left effect gravity has on
it and the the more spin you get on your
breaking ball the more they move
so it's it's the same thing it's just a
different era
and cheating like i i think that's what
we take away from this
cheating is just such a part of baseball
and and we've seen a lot of it these
last few years
before i let you go jeff what what can
you tell me about the grom anything
what's going on with him in the mets i
mean what you know it was
let's put it this way nobody knows jacob
de graham's body better than jacob's
ground
and the fact that after the game last
night he was talking about how he
doesn't feel like this that big of a
deal
uh leads me to believe that he's going
to be okay
but i'm just wondering what's next like
is it going to be
like his coccyx is it going to be like
his appendix
i i i i mean he's had a shoulder and
elbow
uh yeah i mean
like it's been it's been a lot this year
and
if you know i i just don't want jacob
degrom's body
to pay the price for our collective joy
because man it's so much fun to watch
him [ __ ] like he's just
the the closest facsimile i have i was
not covering baseball
you know i was in college during this
time but
uh like 97 98
99 2000 pedro martinez i mean it was
he was just so much better than everyone
else
and so dominant every time he went out
there it was like how are these guys
gonna hit him
and that's what jacob's a gromspin three
innings eight punch outs
perfect and you know the the body
unfortunately rich is just a a fragile
thing whether you are
a superhero like jacob degrom or
a guy who's running a 5-840
i appreciate i assume you're referring
to my 40 and i appreciate you shaving a
couple tenths of a second off jeff you
know
but i just need to rich rich it is it is
your show and if i have to lie to make
you look better then i'm gonna do that
it's okay jeff it's okay uh i'm just
running cold turkey i used to have
spider tack on it that's why i ran
slower
you know i'm just running cold turkey
thanks for the call jeff you are the
best
let's do this again soon call any time
buddy thank you guys
it's jeff passing that jeff passing i i
follow him you should too
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here